[Music]
ethanol has been a matter of intense
debate and lobbying for decades thanks
to the government supported enjoys
currently the renewable fuel standard or
RFS requires refiners to blend ethanol
into their gasoline this drives up
prices at the pump but also at the
grocery store because it diverts
cropland from food production to fuel
production ranchers complain about the
effect on feed prices environmental is
subject to ethanol z' effect on
groundwater in greenhouse gas emissions
but the ethanol industry is politically
strong thanks to the clout of farmers in
Iowa's first in the nation caucuses in
early 2018 a refiner in Philadelphia
filed for bankruptcy blaming the ethanol
mandate the ethanol industry has pushed
back on the Trump administration's plans
to weaken the RFS Congress could end it
and force ethanol to compete in the free
market by passing legislation to wind
down the RFS over five years and some
lawmakers have proposed a bill to do
just that if this passed it would mean
cleaner groundwater cheaper gasoline and
cheaper food do you think Congress will
ever stand up to the farm lobby let us
know in your comments also let us know
what other topics you would like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI